Musik Jetzt kommt das Podcast-Uvo mit Stefan und Florentin, es ist ein guter Podcast, alle Menschen lieben ihn. Jetzt kommt das Podcast-Uvo mit Stefan und Florentin, vielleicht auch mit Thais, das werden wir ja sehen. Jetzt kommt das Podcast UFO mit Stefan Wiesbamos. Wir wünschen euch viel Spaß, die Folge, die geht jetzt los, die Folge, die geht jetzt los. In der Tat, herzlich willkommen zum Das Podcast UFO Podcast. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, gegenüber von mir ist Florentin Will, das ist die Stammbesetzung. Korrekt, ja, das Stammensemble heute Morgen. Das Stammensemble. Wir haben es uns nicht nehmen lassen, nochmal zurück auf die Bühne zu kehren. Vielen Dank an Marcel für dieses fantastische Intro. Es klang aber nach Marcel und jemandem. Ja, ich glaube, da will jemand, sage ich mal, die Macht über die Band an sich reissen. Und das unterstütze ich. Ich glaube, Marcel war sein Vorschlag für den Bandnamen, glaube ich. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, Marcel hat die Lyrics geschrieben, hat den Text geschrieben. Nur weil jetzt irgendwie Jutta den Text singt, ist es trotzdem Marcells Song. Von daher alle liebe Grüße gehen raus an Marcel. Ich muss sagen, ich finde, Jutta hat das ganz toll gemacht. Ich finde, ihr Tomre in der Stimme hat das was ganz Besonderes gemacht. Die hat so ein Lachen im... Ich finde, man hört Lachen raus. Ja, das stimmt. Man hört ein Lachen raus aus der Stimme heraus. Ich finde es auch manchmal merkwürdig, dass bei tatsächlich fröhlichen Songs die Sänger gar nicht so fröhlich klingen. Oder umgekehrt manchmal. Ja, irgendwie komisch. Ich weiß nicht. Bei sehr traurigen Songs hört man die ganze Zeit, der grinst doch, der grinst doch einen ab, weil man hört man auch im Hintergrund so ein ... Der muss dann immer das hinten rausschneiden und irgendwie so Evanescence, irgendwie so Ballade und hinten so rausschneiden. Ja. Du weißt ja, wie es im Tonstudio ist, Stefan. Ich kenne mich da ja aus, das ist ja mein Forte. Ja, ja. Ja. Ja, ja. Ne, klar. Gibt es nicht so einen Raum, wo man verrückt wird, weil der Raum alles schluckt?
Ja. für einen Weltrekordversuch ein bisschen blöd. Ich verstehe, ich kann nicht mehr Luft anhalten. Oder ich kann den Würfel, den Zauberwürfel nicht schneller lösen. Verstehe ich. Hatte keine Lust mehr, finde ich blöd für so einen Weltrekordversuch. Es stimmt schon, Weltrekord ist 45 Minuten, es steht aber auch im Weltrekordbuch dabei, dass es sehr ungeduldige Leute waren. Also um das so ein bisschen in den Kontext zu setzen. Damit man weiß, ah, okay, krass, selbst für eine ungeduldige Person ist 45 Minuten immer noch sehr lang. Ja, da gibt es einen Weltrekordversuch, wo am Ende Leute regelmäßig aufhören, weil kein Bock mehr. Ich glaube schon. Also ein Weltrekordversuch, der mich immer noch fasziniert bis heute ist, die am weitesten mit der Nase gerollte Erbse. Du kannst es ja, ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass da irgendwann der Körper sagt, konditionell, ich bin raus, der Geist sagt irgendwann, das war es jetzt, das ist ja auch lächerlich, wir machen das seit zehn Tagen. Ja, aber ich glaube, die erste Stunde strengt man sich noch an und dann schweifen die Gedanken ab und denken sich, was mache ich mit meinem Leben, wo bin ich falsch abgebogen, dass ich hier auf allen Vieren irgendwie mit meiner Nase die Erbse, Der, mit dem ohr die die erbse rollt der ist drei kilometer weiter und ich dachte mir fuck ich steige um auf die nase um da zumindest noch ein rekord zu schaffen und dann hat man einfach keine lust mehr wann wann war das eine gute idee weltrekords bücher und wann hat der erste mensch gedacht gott also der erste anwalt mit notare gewesen zusammen gesetzt haben und dachten glauben dann Weltrekorde. Ich habe da so ein Video gesehen, wie tatsächlich Guinness Buch der Weltrekorde oft auch missbraucht wird von so Diktatoren aus aller Welt, die einfach sagen, ja, wir haben hier den größten Esel aus Gold. Und dann sagen die Goldeselmacher sagen, wir haben nicht den größten Esel aus Gold. Hallo. Aber das weisst er noch nicht. Hallo, wir haben den noch nicht. Und dann sitzt halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, in Denver, im Hauptquartier des Guinness-Buch-Rekord und sagt, sollen wir jetzt wirklich zu, keine Ahnung, zu irgendwelchen Dispoten im fernen Osten da Leute hinschicken? Ja, mach mal. Und dann hast du da Fototermin und so und dann, klar, sagt dir dann, das ist der grösste Esel. Was soll der sagen? Nein, das klingt für mich eine Lustreise. Diese ganzen Anwälte da in Denver, das klingt für mich auch weirdly specific, dass du den Denver ausgesucht hast. Ich war mal großer Fan tatsächlich des Guinness-Buch der Weltrekorde Weltrekords. Die sitzen in Denver? Ja, ja, die sitzen in Denver. Die grösste Guinness-Buch der Weltrekorde-Redaktion der Welt tatsächlich ist in Denver. Gibt es denn auch einen deutschen Ableger? Die schreiben sich jedes Mal auch selber in das Buch ein. Gibt es einen deutschen, weil die schon am längsten das machen wahrscheinlich. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Es ist auch irgendwo auch weird, wo hört das auf, wo fängt das an? Ich habe auch bestimmt schon mal irgendwas in den Weltreport gebrochen, ohne es zu wissen. Weiß ich nicht. Bestimmt. Doch, mit Sicherheit. Also jetzt, ich will nicht so nahe treten, aber ich glaube, du bist sehr durchschnittlich, was so alles, was so dein normales Tag zu Tag angeht. Jüngster Netflix-Autor. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Bo Burnham? Wahrscheinlich schon. Mit Netflix. Und älter. Okay. Aber gut. Gut. Ja, komm, lassen wir es. Aber ich finde, wo wir uns noch zum Thema keine Lust mehr. Ich finde es immer schade, dass zum Beispiel, wenn sich Bands auflösen oder so, dann hört man immer kreative Differenzen oder andere Wege gehen. Tot. Aber niemand sagt, ja, wir haben einfach keinen Bock mehr.
Okay, keine Lust mehr.
Obwohl wahrscheinlich bei den meisten das der Grund ist.
Wir haben einfach keine Lust mehr.
Ich glaube, für die meisten Dinge, die enden, ist kein Bock mehr die Erklärung.
Aber man hört es dafür sehr selten, finde ich auch.
Extrem selten.
Es ist auch schade, dass es immer dann so PR-mäßig auf so eine Firma irgendwie, ja, wir sind
bankrott gegangen, kann man einfach sagen, wir haben einfach keinen Bock mehr. Was mache ich eigentlich, ich bin einfach zurückgerollt. Auf Granit, Stefan podcastet einfach auf Granit, auf dem Granit. Das ist auch egal. Lustigerweise, bei allem, wo man es weiß, ist Nico Rosberg, der Formel-1-Rennfahrer, der dann Weltmeister wurde zum ersten Mal und dann aufgeallt hat mit der Begründung, ja, keinen Bock mehr. War das nicht auch der, der gesagt hat, macht es gar keinen Spaß, Formel 1 zu fahren? Das weiß ich nicht, doch, das macht ihm schon Spaß. Er ist ja jetzt auch noch Experte und so einen Scheiß und aus seinem Jugendzimmer twitcht er ab und zu und sagt, hey, das war interessant bei dem Rennen bei dem Letzten. Aber er hat einfach relativ klar gesagt, das ist ja wahnsinnig anstrengend. Ich habe eine Frau und ein Kind, ich habe einfach keinen Bock mehr. Oder er war halt der Weltmeister und ich verstehe das total. Weil natürlich willst du dir irgendwas der Beste sein. Jeder sucht sich dann irgendwie ein Ding aus, was ihm Spaß macht, wo er nicht am besten gut drin ist, will darin dann der Beste werden und dann ist auch gut. Was willst du denn noch mehr? Du willst das dann mehr. Vor allem als Formel-1-Rennfahrer ist ja relativ klar belegt, dass du der Beste warst. Aber ich habe mal von irgendeinem gehört, dass es irgendeinen Formel-1-Fahrer gab, der irgendwann mal gesagt hat, ihm hat es nie Spaß gemacht, er fand es nie, also er war halt sehr gut darin und hat Preise gewonnen und das war halt sein Beruf, aber so wie es genug Leute gibt, die es ein Büro geben, lustlos jeden Tag, war das für den halt einfach ein Job, so ich gehe da hin, fahre da im Kreis und dann war es das. Aber das ist lustig, weil die meisten Jobs, wo du in der Öffentlichkeit stehst, sind ja eigentlich nicht dafür gemacht, dass man keinen Bock hat, weil das sind ja beneidenswerte Jobs. Und ich finde es auch interessant, dass es eine Diskrepanz geben kann zwischen Dingen, die mir Spaß machen und Dingen, die ich gut kann. Man geht eigentlich immer davon aus, dass was man gut kann, macht einem auch Spaß und andersrum. Ich finde aber auch, das ist eigentlich die Regel, finde ich aber auch, weil du in dem, was dir Spaß macht, bist du besser, weil du damit mehr Zeit deines Lebens verbringst. Gut, aber es können ja, ich meine, du machst ja nur die Dinge, die dir Spaß machen. Vielleicht bist du der beste Golfer der Welt. Nein, ich glaube... Aber du hast noch nie gegolft. Das ist die alte Diskussion. Ich behaupte ja, es gibt kein Talent. Menschen haben kein Talent. Du bist geboren als Fleischklumpen. Aber warum bist du dann so verdammt gut, Stefan? Worin bin ich gut? Sag mir, ich bin, glaube ich, in Golf. Podcasten? Podcasten. Warum bist du so verdammt gut? Warum überschattest du mich jede Woche? Wie machst du das? Erst mal, das ist nicht der Fall. Ich sag immer, lustigerweise in vielen Interviews, sag ich immer, wo auch dann irgendwann kommt, hast du ein Talent dafür, sag ich immer, das Beispiel, du bist gut vom Mikrofon, sag ich immer, weil du ja auch damals als Kind schon Bock hattest, die Kassettenrekorde aufzunehmen und so weiter und hast Radiosendungen moderiert und so, hast gerne Leute unterhalten und so weiter. Das heißt, du hast früh dieses Spaß, diese Passion, hast du trainiert und wurdest dann natürlich immer besser darin. Und ich glaube, dass das ist natürlich viel komplexer als ein Talent zu haben oder das, was wir gerade machen, ist ja was sehr spezielles.
Ich glaube nicht, dass so das speziell trainiert ein Talent zu haben oder das, was wir gerade machen, ist ja was sehr spezielles.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du das speziell trainiert hast die ganze Zeit, aber Dinge in diesem Umfeld, Leute unterhalten, sprechen, spontan sein, sich Dinge ausdenken, kreativ sein, Kunstinteresse haben. Das ist alles schon verankert in deiner Vergangenheit, deswegen bist du jetzt besser als andere. Okay, aber ist es denn nicht noch arroganter, wenn du erfolgreich bist und dann sagst, es gibt kein Talent, weil du dann einfach sagst, nee, ich bin einfach noch ein Stück noch krasser, weil sonst kann man einfach sagen, ja gut, David Bowie ist halt einfach talentiert, der kann das halt einfach passt, aber wenn er sagt, nee, es gibt kein Talent, durch harte Arbeit. Ich finde diese Leute, die sagen, der ist einfach talentiert, das ist einfach eine faule Ausrede. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich glaube, es gibt ja auch die wenigsten Menschen, die sagen, es geht ausschliesslich um Talent.
Ja, nee, klar, das sowieso. Ich behaupte einfach, es gibt es nicht. Ein Puzzlestück im Puzzlerfolg. Ich glaube, das Wort Talent wird falsch benutzt. Talent ist eher so die Aneinanderkettung von Erfahrungen in dem Bereich. Grob in dem Bereich. Das ist meine Definition von Talent. Gut, und das muss man jedes Mal sagen. Eine Aneinanderkettung, ja, lass das Wort Talent aus deinem Vokabular, ihr müsst jedes Mal sagen, und wir setzen es durch das Wort? Nein, durch den geflügelten Begriff, eine Aneinanderkettung der Dinge im grob im gleichen Bereich. Eine Aneinanderkettung ähnlicher Dinge, die so grob im gleichen Bereich herumspielen. Vielleicht kriegt man dann Akronyme hin, dass man dann so abkürzt, so Bebock. Was dann wieder Talent ergeben, dummerweise. Ach Gott, wir drehen uns im Kreis. So wurden eigentlich, glaube ich, auch Ursprünger alle Worte erfunden. Ja, und es war immer das Wort Talent, wo man auch gesagt hat, Leute, naja. Aber das ist, glaube ich, wirklich ist das der Fall. Ich bin in meinem Leben noch nie einem Menschen begegnet, der von null auf gut in etwas ist.
Man sagt das immer oft bei ... Ich war mal mit einem Sportstudenten befreundet, der immer sehr gut in anderen Sportarten war.
Und alle haben immer gesagt, du bist so ein Naturtalent, im Golf haben wir dann am Wochenende gemacht oder so.
Und man immer sagt, nein, der hat einfach eine wahnsinnig gute Körperbeherrschung, weil der ist ein Sportler, der studiert das, der setzt sich jeden Tag mit seinem Körper auseinander, der weiß, wie Muskeln funktionieren, der weiß, wo Dinge in seinem Körper sind. Und wir zum Beispiel wissen das nicht. Aber ich weiß auch, wo Dinge ... Nein, brauchst du jetzt gar nicht, nicht daraus reden. Was soll das jetzt heißen, er weiß, wie Muskeln funktionieren? Gibt es da so eine Art Gangschaltung, man muss da irgendwas lernen, damit man sein ... Nee, Nervenbahnen sind einfach besser trainiert. Die Nervenbahnen, ich glaube, die sind einfach, so wurde es mir erklärt, die sind einfach, die werden häufiger benutzt, du weißt, wie du Dinge ansteuern kannst, du kannst viel effektiver, bessere Körperbeherrschung, Koordination und so weiter. Und wir beide, wir wissen noch gar nicht, wenn wir jetzt den kleinen Zeh strecken wollen, du hast den verloren bei einem blöden Accident.
So, ich weiss noch nicht mehr, wie ich den ansteuere.
Ich kann kleiner C, kleiner C
denken, weiß aber nicht, was passiert.
So bewegst du dich, dass du immer
das Körperteil denkst, dass jetzt
auch wenn ich nach rechts gehen will,
denke ich immer rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts.
Und dann merke ich, dass der Körper langsam
sie langsam driftet. Aber da du es gerade sagst,
ich hatte heute meinen letzten Orthopäden-Termin.
Und hast du sie gefragt? Das ist die entscheidende Frage. Hast du sie auf die Homöopathie an? Bestanden, ich habe mein Zeh zurück in meiner Gewalt. Und das war eigentlich der merkwürdigste Termin, den ich jene hatte. So einen Termin hatte ich noch nie. Wo man sich, wo man trifft, ich war zwei Stunden im Wartezimmer, und dann Herr Will und dann so, und alles gut? Ja, gut, dann passt ja alles, dann brauchen wir keinen weiteren Termin warum sagst du nicht einfach das ist eine verdammt gute Frage ich dachte der wird da nochmal geröntgend oder oder die drückt da nochmal drauf rum einfach so ja Wortfrage geröntget geröntgt ich röntge du röntgest er sie es wird geröntgen wir röntgen ja nee das ist nicht falsch ich meine das passiv wir werden geröntget er wird geröntgen. Ja, nee, das ist nicht falsch, ich meine das passiv. Wir werden geröntget. Geröntget. Er wird geröntget? Never. Sorry. Röntgent. Nein, geröntget. Der hieß ja Röntgen. Röntgen, geröntgt. Also, ich werde geröntget. Nee, geröntgt. Geröntgt. Geröntgt? Tickete. Geröntgt. Tickete. Geröntgete, nee, Gerönteketet. So, ich wurde schön durchleuchtet, beziehungsweise nicht, und ich wurde schön bestrahlt, und dann war es so ein, weil es ist ja schon, also mit Ärzten, man lernt sich ja doch kennen, man ist intim, man zeigt einem widerlichen Ausschlag. Ein Team oder ein Team? Genitalbereich. Man ist ein intimes Team, so wie ein Team sein sollte. Und dann so nach so sechs Treffen sagt man dann so, ja und jetzt sehen wir uns nie wieder. Nie wieder. Sie sind weiter Arzt, ich bin kein Patient mehr. Für die nächste überschaubare Zeit. Du weißt ja auch nicht genau, was passiert.
Unsere Verbindung wird getrennt und dann ist es schon so ein, was sagt man
da an? Nehmt man sich in den Arm. Und dann sagt man
danke für alles?
Nee, ich bin einfach gegangen, ich habe
einfach den Tschüss gesagt, aber auch ganz
merkwürdig immer so mit den, wenn dann
die Ärztin und dann noch eine Assistentin im Raum
ist und die Assistentin schaut nur auf
dem Rechner oder so und dann sagt man dann
Wiedersehen und dann habe ich auch noch die
Die... Merkwürdig immer so, wenn dann die Ärztin und dann noch eine Assistentin im Raum ist und die Assistentin schaut nur auf dem Rechner oder so und dann sagt man dann Wiedersehen und dann habe ich auch noch die Assistentin, habe ich mich so seitlich so gekrümmt, so in der Hüfte gekrümmt.
Und dabei hast du die VNC angestossen. Ciao und die gar nicht. Es ist interessant, wie viel muss sie beisteuern, dass sie noch ein eigenes Ciao verdient hat? Ich habe neulich über mich selber gelernt, dass ich wahnsinnig gerne Ciao sage.
Ich verabschiede mich so gerne und auch laut, viel zu laut auch, wenn ich beim Bäcker rausgehe.
Und auch zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt, also man ist im Laden, Beispiel, man ist im Laden und kauft ein T-Shirt.
So, dann, was für ein Beispiel?
Kurses Beispiel, ist schön zu veranschaulichen.
Dann kaufe ich dieses Shirt, dann bezahlt man und so weiter, dann sagen die, alles klar, schönen Tag noch, ich sage, danke gleichfalls und dann beginne ich erst den Einpackprozess, weil davor war ich mit Zahlen beschäftigt. Also nehme ich mein Shirt, mache meinen Rucksack auf, stelle den hin, stehe noch gut zehn Minuten vor dem Menschen, der gerade gesagt hat, schönen Tag noch. Ja, machst deine lächerlich winzige Geldbörse auf, sortierst da die Münzen rein, genau, die magnetisch alle aufgeladen sind, aneinander hängen, Münzreihe. Das ist auch ein Problem, es hängt mein Schlüssel da immer dran, weil das magnetisch ist, es ist einfach nicht auszuhalten. Jedenfalls, genau, dann irgendwann tauche ich wieder auf, weil ich von meinem Rucksack hochkomme und alles reingepackt habe und dann sage ich sehr laut nochmal Tschüss, obwohl, obwohl die Verabschiedung schon vorbei war. Und da bestehe ich auch immer drauf, mein Recht noch zu sagen, Tschüss, schönen Tag, ciao, ciao, einfach um ... Und dann die Verkäuferin, die schon mit dem nächsten Kunden zu tun, dann so, ja, ciao, ciao. Auch beim Bäcker, sage ich immer noch Ciao. Und dann ist sie schon mit einem anderen Kunden zugange. Aber ich nehme das raus, weil es ist so befreiend. Du bist fertig mit diesem Teil deines Tages. Ich habe da eine Geschichte gelesen, da musste ich an dich denken. Hamster. Meine Familie hat einen Hamster. Und eines Tages, der Hamster, merken Sie, der sitzt so ganz still, nur noch in der Ecke von seinem Käfig rum. Ganz kurz, bin ich in dieser Geschichte, der Hamster oder derjenige, der Hamsterbesitzer, haben die dem was zu fressen gegeben und er wollte nichts mehr fressen. Und er sass dann nur ganz still, aber hat schon noch geatmet und so und war. Ja, aber sie wussten nicht, was los ist, was mit dem los ist.
Nächster Tag immer noch nichts gefressen.
Jetzt, Mensch, was ist denn los mit dem?
Bisschen in den Käfig gerüttelt, ein bisschen gestreichelt irgendwie, was ist da los? An den Ausschalter. Er sass nur ganz still da, hat sich nicht mehr bewegt. Nächster Tag, ja. Oh, die Geschichte ist echt lang, oder? Was ist da los, jetzt müssen wir schon langsam was machen? Der hatte seit drei Tagen... Wie lange müsstest du diese Geschichte genauso weiter erzählen, bis ich irgendwann die Folge abbreche?
Da haben sie sich gedacht, na gut, einen Tag noch, vielleicht vierter Tag, immer noch nichts gefressen. Also, na gut, jetzt müssen wir mal wirklich zum Tierarzt gehen. Nehmen die den Käfig, Tür auf, Schuhe an. Erst nimmt man erst den Käfig mit an die Tür und dann Schuhe. Ist es so breit wie die Tür, muss man den quer. Seitlich reichen es durch Fenster raus. Auf jeden Fall fahren sie dann ins Krankenhaus, Tierkrankenhaus. Tierkrankenhaus? Tierarzt? In die Tierklinik. Neeik und dann gucken sie ab, Pferde nach links, Pfauen nach rechts, Mitte durch, für uns geht es weiter, Mitte. Dann kommen sie in die Graffe mit so einer Halskrause, mit einer ganz langen Halskrause entgegen. Wir brauchen mehr Halskrause! Mehr Halskrause mit dem Trakt B. Und die Schlange einfach so ein langer Gips. Ein langer Gips rollt seitlich. Entschuldigung, können Sie bitte Platz machen? So zwei Löcher drin sind für die Augen ansonsten komplett gegipst. Und dann halt so lange, bis die Hamsterausfahrt kam. So, hier müssen wir links abbiegen. Also rein, Käfig im Kofferraum, rein zum Tierarzt und dann ja, gucken sich der mal an und dann warten sie vor der Tür, ja was sagt der Tierarzt jetzt und dann sagt der Tierarzt, nee, mit dem ist alles in Ordnung.
Also der ist völlig gesund, aber was uns aufgefallen ist, er hatte Magneten in der Backe. Und zwar hat er Tage davor unter dem Kühlschrank es rumgekrabbelt, hat anscheinend einen Kühlschrankmagneten gefressen, in der Backe gehabt und war in seinem Käfig einfach nur an den Käfigstangen festmagnetisiert und kam dann nicht mehr weg. Er kam einfach nicht mehr weg. In der Hamstersprache war es die ganze Zeit ein, kann er nicht mehr essen! Ich kann nicht mehr weg! Und die, was ist mit dem, der arme Hamster war einfach festmagnetisiert am Käfig. Gott im Himmel. Grauenhaft, grauenhaft. Der arme Hamster. Und da musste ich auch sehr an dich denken, wie du gerade irgendwo so mit deiner Tasche... Ich hing die ganze letzte Woche, hing ich an der Busch an der Stelle. Mit deiner magnetischen Geldbörse. Aber was ist mit ihm? Und du hängst so an der Strassenbahn, die Strassenbahn fährt los und du
nein, nein, nein!
Einfach den ganzen Tag
hast du Probleme mit dem
Magnet. Ja, ist ein Problem, aber
das ist ja wirklich fantastisch.
Der arme Hamster, aber haben die nicht mal da reingeguckt
oder den genommen oder so?
Den kannst du doch einfach nehmen. Nee, irgendwie nicht.
Der hat einfach nicht wegnehmen, der dachte, der ist halt einfach
schlapp, aber er hing einfach
da. In der Backe. Und der Hamster kann
das halt auch nicht kommunizieren. Oder war das, hat er es noch in der Backe gehabt, in der Mache, oder hat er den in dem Darm getragen? Nee, nee, in der Backe. Also die Hamster, die hamstern ja in ihren Backen so Sachen und da war der Magnet halt drin. Das, aber gut, dass er es noch vom Kühlschrank in den Käfig geschafft hat. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß noch nicht, was er dachte. Aber ich finde die Vorstellung, dass der Tierarzt den auch so abzieht. Und dann wird der direkt irgendwie direkt in den Kühlschrank geschleudert. Und der Tierarzt, Moment mal, das ist ungewöhnlich. Dann nimmt er so ein Holzstück, das ist jetzt nichts. Dann nimmt er eine Plastikflasche, wieder nichts. Dann nimmt er eine Eisenstange und plüpp und er weiss, ding ding, ich bin kein Physiker, aber das hat ein System. Dann Aluminium, nichts. Aber auch so die Frage, kriegt man den Magneten dann wieder? Ja, gute Frage. Oder haben die jetzt, das Krankenhaus bereichert sich, glaube ich, an vielen Orten. Ja, dem richtig. Aber mir gefällt die Vorstellung eines Tierkrankenhauses eigentlich sehr. Ja. Schade, dass es was denn nicht gibt. Es ist ja eher dann Tierklinik, Tierpraxen. Wo man auch denkt, Tiere können nicht so krank sein, weil ein Mensch alle Tiere behandeln kann. Nee, vor allem bei Tieren sagt man ja, wenn sie sehr krank sind, dass sie ein Krankenhausfall, also so ein Intensivstationfall ist ja dann immer Einschläfern.
Ja.
Wo man auch sagt, bei Menschen greift man selten zum Einschläfern. Da macht der Mensch dann noch einen ganz schönen grossen Cut zwischen Tier und Mensch.
Ja, ich habe...
Sehr anthropozentristisch.
Habe ich letztens ein Bild gesehen, wo so ein wirklich winziger Fisch operiert wurde.
Ja, lächerlich.
Dem wurde so ein Tumor ausoperiert.
Ja, gut. Ein Gramm Fisch. Ein Gramm! Winziger Fisch operiert wurde. Ja, lächerlich. Dem wurde so ein Tumor ausoperiert. Ja, gut. Ein Gramm Fisch, ein Gramm winziger Fisch. Und dann hat er gesagt, nee, komm, holst du raus. Und dann hat er auch Magneten. Das war doch ein Magnet. Alles Magneten, ja, ist ein Problem. Es kommt ja immer mehr magnetisches Metall ins Meer. Und wir wissen nicht, was daraus wird. Die ganzen Ortungssysteme der Wale drehen durch, weil die sich ja auch an... Alle Magneten gefressen haben. Ja, alle haben alle Magneten gefressen. Bald hängen die alle in meinem Pormonee, oder was? Das war auch ein schöner Begriff eigentlich, wenn jemand so ein bisschen schlapp drauf ist. Sag mal, du hast heute immer Magneten gefressen, oder was? Etabliert das mal, die Podcast-Suche-Community etabliert das mal, wenn jemand so... Weil, wie gesagt, ich sag's, vielleicht muss ich es gar nicht mehr erwähnen, aber tatsächlich hat Shakespeare relativ viele Redewendungen und Worte erfunden. Und wir versuchen's seit Wochen, seit Jahren mit Smisma, Klapp auch nicht. Smisma wird nichts. Du musst mal vielleicht einfach ein bisschen aufgeben. Aber vielleicht einfach, vielleicht kriegen wir Sinn, du hast doch einen Magneten gefressen. Na, wer hat denn heute einen Magneten gefressen? Gefrühstückt, vielleicht auch. Einen Magneten gefrühstückt. Gefrühstückt, ja, und all den ist nicht, du meinst Clown. Nee. Nee, Podcast ist so eine Art Internet-Radiosendung. Wie oft musst du noch Podcast erklären eigentlich? Jedes Mal, ja, und mich nervt es. Also stell dir mal vor, also angenommen, wir wären ein Buch, so eine Buchreihe. Stell dir gerade vor ein Buch, in dem geschrieben steht, tu mir mal so, als wäre ich ein Podcast. Ja, Was würde das jetzt ändern gerade? Oder wäre eine Radiosendung oder so. Wie anders unser Leben wäre, weil ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind in etwas, wir sind ja schon ein erfolgreicher Podcast. Muss man schon auch mal sagen. Du haust heute aber raus, du hast kein Talent, du musst es hart arbeiten, du bist überdurchschnittlich gut, du bist der beste Podcaster. Was hast du vor der Sendung gesagt? Habe ich gerade noch gesagt. Du hast gesagt, aber du meinst einmal Stefan, ich bin der beste Podcast. Ich bin schon der beste Podcast. Nein, aber muss man ja schon sagen, so verhältnismäßig, wir tauchen in Top-Fünften-Listen auf, da kann man ja auch mal das sagen, ist ja jetzt auch nichts Schlimmes. Wegen unseren tollen Fans. Wegen unseren tollen Fans, natürlich. Aber, das wollte ich einfach nur sagen. Nee, aber stell dir mal vor, es ist etwas sehr Spezielles, in dem man erfolgreich ist. Und das ist da auch so ein Ding, will man denn etwas sehr Spezielles im Erfolgreichsein oder will man nicht lieber, eine Fernsehsendung, eine erfolgreiche Fernsehende zu haben, ist natürlich viel breiter. Wir haben uns schon was Weirdes ausgesucht. Vielleicht haben wir einen Fehler gemacht. Aus dem falschen Feldgesetz. Es stimmt schon, dieses, also wir kriegen ja manchmal Mails von so Medienstudenten, habe ja schon oft erzählt, die Facharbeiten über Podcast schreiben, Bachelorarbeit und ich lese diese Bachelorarbeit und ich habe ein einziges Kriterium. Ein einziges Kriterium. Macht's besser. Macht's besser. Wenn in der Arbeit erklärt wird, was ein Podcast ist, lese ich es nicht. Interessiert es mich nicht. Weil wenn das der Punkt ist, den deine Leser, den du voraussetzt, dann kann da nichts Interessantes drinstehen. Kann da einfach nichts Interessantes drinstehen. Wenn irgendwie ein Biologe eine Doktorarbeit schreibt, oder Wölfe. Erstmal, was sind Wunde? Ja, über Wölfe. Und Seite 1 ist, ein Wolf hat vier Pfoten, ein Wolf hat ein Fell. Ist ein Hundewesen. Ist ein hundeartiges Wesen, oder wird schon technisch. Wo ich mir denke, was kann da drinstehen, was so besonders ist, wenn das denn... Wo treibt es das Feld der Wolfsforschung weiter?
Genau, ja, wo jetzt... Man muss einfach mal Dinge annehmen, damit man sagen kann, okay, wir haben es verstanden, was ein Podcast ist, jetzt weiter, ja, von mir aus verschiedene Themen.
Gute Frage, wann wird ein Podcast nicht mehr erklärt?
Ich glaube, es hängt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen vielleicht daran, dass viele Studenten denken, ihre Professoren wissen selbst gar nicht, was ein Podcast ist und müssen es dem erklären oder der oder... Keine E-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di man mag. Weil erst mal nicht objektiv. Du hörst selber gerne Podcasts und sagst, jetzt schreibe ich eine Facharbein Doktorarbeit über Podcasts, wenn ich sage, ja, Bullshit, unwissenschaftlich. Schreib über Ballett, über was, was dich überhaupt nicht interessiert, weil wenn es um Wissenschaft geht, dann ist es wichtig. Du willst einfach nicht länger damit beschäftigen, womit du dich überhaupt ohnehin schon beschäftigt. Ja, genau. Ich schreibe eine Doktorarbeit über die Simpsons, ja, du willst einfach nur Simpsons-Folgen gucken den ganzen Tag. So, da wird dann nichts Sinnvolles bei rauskommen. Jetzt tu mal nicht so, du wärst der Erste, der etwas hinzuschreiben würde.
Nee, überhaupt, nee, wirklich gar nicht.
Ich denke mir aber auch, was man hasst, sollte man auch nicht machen, weil das man auch nicht objektiv.
Eigentlich, wo man maximale Distanz zu hat, dass er irgendeinem Grunde kommt.
Wo einfach maximale wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse daraus entspringen kann.
Aber so funktioniert es nicht, glaube ich.
Natürlich funktioniert es noch nicht.
Macht doch niemand so.
Ich glaube, selbst Wissenschaftler, deren Erkenntnisse für das Wissen der Menschheit verantwortlich sind, selbst die machen nur das, worauf sie Bock haben, primär, weil sonst drehst du doch durch in deinem Leben.
Ich hies gerade ein sehr spannendes Buch über Ernährung, was wirklich interessant ist. Es heisst In Defense of Food und es geht darum, weil ich habe mich ja wirklich, Seite eins, you needed to live. Ja, der erste Satz ist, eat food, mostly plants, eat less food, mostly plants oder sowas ist glaube ich der erste Satz, weil es geht tendenziell darum, dass die Menschheit keine Ahnung hat von Ernährung. Bis heute weiss man nicht, im Darmtrakt sind ähnlich viele Nervenzellen wie in der Wirbelsäule. Und man weiss nicht warum. Was machen die da alle? Niemand weiss es, niemand hat keine Antwort. Was wollen die da? Warum gibt es so viele Nervenzellen? Aber was heißt Nervenzellen? Man fühlt ja da nichts. Neuronen, Neurons. Okay, ich bin mir nicht sicher genau. Nee, genau, man fühlt da nichts. Aber das läuft genauso viel zusammen wie in der Wirbelsäule, wo ja das alles zusammenläuft, wie so ein großer Kabelbinder, stelle ich mir das vor. Man fragt sich, was macht das da unten? Und dann, auch hier gab es ja diesen, es gibt immer in jedem Sachbuch diesen einen Trottelwissenschaftler, in diesem Fall ist es Justus von Liebig, der irgendwann erkannt hat, dass Nahrung aus den drei Hauptbestandteilen Protein, Fett und Kohlenhydrate besteht. Und er hat dann gesagt, ja, das reicht, das war's. Und hat dann angefangen, Babynahrung zu entwickeln, die nur diese drei Bestandteile haben. Mit seiner Karriere mal zu spielen. Und sich nie wieder um das Thema gekümmmmert. Nee, dann hat er gesagt, Menschen brauchen nur diese drei Sachen zum Leben, war ich bis er das entdeckt, hat dann Babynahrung entwickelt, die genau so funktioniert, und alle Kinder wurden unterentwickelt, weil er halt einfach alle Vitamine vergessen hat, alle anderen Fette, er hat alles vergessen, Omega-3, also Aminosäuren und so, alles vergessen, hat er gesagt, diese drei Dinge, die mehr brauchen wir nicht, mehr brauchen wir, ich weiß jetzt alles über Ernährung. Es gibt immer diesen einen Trottel, der an irgendeinem Punkt gesagt hat, ich weiss jetzt alles. Es sind immer, also sagt das nie, es sind meiner Erfahrung nach immer die Trottel der Geschichte, es sind Leute, die behaupten, ich kann jetzt alles, ich weiss jetzt alles. Immer die Trottel, die coolsten sind immer die, die sagen, ich weiss gar nichts. Gut, aber wann fängst du an, Babynahrung zu machen, weil du kannst ja, wenn man heute noch nicht an dem Punkt ist, dass man weiss, wie alles funktioniert, kannst du ja nie anfangen, Leben nachzudenken. Gebt dem einfach Muttermilch. That's the whole mystery. Oder akzeptiert er, dass es dann unzulänglich ist, egal was man denn gerade gibt. Vielleicht gibt es manche Dinge, die schon ganz gut sind, aber die sind noch nicht perfekt. Jedenfalls weiß man so wenig über Ernährung und es ist auch so ein Quatsch, dann gab es ja irgendwann, es geht vor allem um die Ernährung in den USA und weil da auch gerade so sehr darauf beachtet wird und so niemand gerne mehr isst, einfach weil er Bock hat zu essen, sondern immer, es geht immer um Kohlenhydrate, es geht immer um Transfette und so einen Scheiß und da darf man gesättigte Fettsäuren essen oder es sind ungesättigte Fettsäuren, es geht immer um ein grosses Chaos und eigentlich geht es immer nur darum, dass die Foodlobby den Markt vergrößern will und neue Produkte auf den Markt bringen soll, die irgendwie gekauft werden dann, die einen Hype auslösen, einfach weil der Markt sich ja nicht mehr so ist, dass die Foodlobby den Markt vergrößern will und neue Produkte auf den Markt bringen soll, die irgendwie gekauft werden, die einen Hype auslösen, einfach weil der Markt sich ja nicht mehr so ist, dass die Foodlobby den Markt vergrößern will und neue Produkte auf den Markt bringen soll, die irgendwie gekauft werden, die einen Hype auslösen, die einen Hype auslösen, einfach weil der Markt sich ja nicht mehr so ist, dass die Produkte auf den Markt vergrössern will, die sich ja nicht mehr so ist, dass die Produkte auf den Markt vergrössern will, die sich ja nicht mehr so ist, dass die Produkte auf den Markt vergrössern will, die sich ja nicht mehr so ist, dass die Produkte auf den Markt vergrössern will, die sich ja nicht mehr so ist, dass die Produkte auf den Markt bringen, die sich ja auch nicht mehr so ist, dass die Produkteächst, und der Bedarf an Essen nimmt nicht sonderlich zu. Du brauchst halt Menschen essen, was sie essen, und werden morgen nicht mehr essen plötzlich. Das heisst, aber der Essensmarkt will ja wachsen, der will ja Kapital erwirtschaften und deswegen funktioniert das nicht und deswegen werden Dinge erfunden und die instrumentalisieren auch dann die Wissenschaftler, die keine Ahnung haben von Ernährung. Ganz spannend eigentlich. Und da denke ich mir auch, die Wissenschaftler, die werden ja auch bezahlt von den ganzen Konzernen, die dann diese Essens, die sich irgendwelche Dinge ausdenken. Und du hast ja auch für das Buch gezahlt. Ja. Das heißt, welche Rolle spielst du eigentlich in dem ganzen System? Wer hat hier die Fäden in der Hand, fragt man sich. Wer ist der eigentliche Hintermann? Ja, jedenfalls bin ich jetzt ein bisschen beruhigter. Das Buch wurde von einer Freundin empfohlen, weil ich ja jetzt wirklich viel abgenommen habe und auf Ernährung geachtet habe und mir wirklich zu viele Gedanken gemacht habe. Und das ist wirklich die perfekte Buchempfehlung für jemanden, der das hat. Der sich zu viele Gedanken über Ernährung macht. Der sich zu viele Gedanken über Ernährung macht und zu viel Quatsch auch behauptet vielleicht und dann auch gedacht, jetzt muss ich Proteine essen, weil ich mache Sport. Und so ist dann einfach genau richtig, dieses Buch ist das exakte Gegenprogramm. Esst, habt Spaß dabei, esst weniger, einfach ein bisschen.
Gut, das heißt, ich glaube, wir dürfen jetzt offiziell die nächste Phase von Stefan wieder einläuten, oder? Er wird wieder fett. Stefan wird wieder fett. Es geht wieder bergauf und in zwei Monaten kommst du hier reingetorkelt, aber er war wieder richtig fett. Nee, also, ich glaube, it is eat less, mostly plants, eat food, ich weiß nicht, diesen Satz, den ich mir zu sagen. Das ist der erste Satz. Eat less food, eat food, some are spicy, mostly plants and eat less. Die haben eine schöne Formel. Ist jedenfalls ein tolles Buch, in defense of food, kann ich nur empfehlen. Ich hatte heute eine Spaghetti, die doppelt war. Wie doppelt? Also einmal die normale Spaghetti-Länge, dann ein U-Turn und dann nochmal die komplette Spaghetti-Länge. Ja. Da stand jetzt nichts im Buch drin. Nee? Nee. Aber bist du schon durch mit dem Buch? Nicht, dass da noch irgendwas kommt. Nee, ich bin noch nicht durch. Vielleicht kommt da noch was. Es kommt, habe ich schon gehört, Völker, die sich ausschließlich von gewissen Dingen ernähren. Vielleicht kommt das Spaghetti-Volk noch. Aber interessant, weil dann hat man manchmal so einen kleinen Einblick in so eine Fabrik, weil man hat ja so Produkte, die kommen ja alle aus Fabriken. Und du weißt ja nicht genau, wie die hergestellt werden. Manchmal hat man so einen Hinweis. Weil jetzt dadurch, dass ich weiss, dass die wahrscheinlich so ursprünglich aussehen und dann werden die, also du hast wahrscheinlich eine lange Spaghetti, dann werden die einmal über einen Balken gelegt und dann trocknen die aus und dann werden die nochmal so abgeschnitten, dass dieses U-Teil weg ist. Aber wo sind diese U-Teile dann? Ich glaube, die gibt es nicht. Ich glaube... Aber kommen, werden die nochmal... Nee, du kannst ja aber einfach oben an den Balken ja auch einen Cut machen, dann hast du kein U mehr, weißt du? Ja, aber die Tatsache, dass ich diese U-Spagetti gefunden habe, muss ja, glaube ich, zeigt darauf, dass alle mal so waren. Aber dann ist ja die Frage obsolet, wo die U-Teile sind. Bei dir. Alle. Nein, aber ich habe ja nur ein U-Teil. Wo sind, also was passiert mit denen in der Fabrik? Werden die dann nochmal zu anderen Nudeln? Ja, ich behaupte, es gibt diesen Balken nicht. Aus welchem Material soll der Balken eine große weitere Spaghetti überhaupt? Ja, halt mit einer Metallstange, wo die drübergelegt werden. Ich fand mich gerade trotzdem lustig. Aber ich glaube, oben kann man ja cutten. Warum sollte es diesen Balken geben überhaupt? Da hängt ja nichts im Trockenen auf, oder? Naja, aber warum sollten die Trons sonst diese lange U-Form haben, wie so eine lange Stimmgabel, so ganz lang und dann oben gekrümmt? Ich fand es faszinierend, aber ich habe mir die Frage auch nicht beantworten können. Ich hätte es natürlich mit der Spaghetti-Doku anschauen können, hätte ich ein paar Fakten auffahnen können über Spaghetti Ich wünsche mir für die nächste Folge ein bisschen Spaghetti-Information. Bisschen Spaghetti-Information? Ja. Der Singular von Spaghetti ist Spaghetto. Spaghetto. Una Spaghetto per favore. Per favore. Una Spaghetto Carbonari. Stronzo. Per favore. Per favore. Es ist sehr kompliziert. Es ist sehr kompliziert, ist es wirklich sehr kompliziert? Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Jedenfalls sehr spannend. Ich finde vor allem immer wieder interessant, wie wenig man über Ernährung weiss, dafür, dass man jeden Tag sich ernähren muss als Mensch. Die Erklärung aber ist, wir als Menschheit sind ja gesund. Wir sind ja die gesunden Überbleibsel der Generation vor uns. Und das ist ja schon seit Jahren Millionen. So, vielleicht ist es ganz gut, wie wir uns immer ernährt haben schon. Und es muss nicht diese Dinge geben, die es jetzt gibt. Vor allem, man passt sich auch an, ne? Der Mensch heute isst wahnsinnig viel Zucker und in ein paar Generationen ist es Passes halt, hat sich der Körper dem angepasst. Man sollte dem Fortschritt nicht im Weg stehen. Auch geil, dass jetzt gerade so eine Carbs sind der Feind Stimmung herrscht. Wirklich? Ja, Kohlenhydrate sind, meiden Kohlenhydrate machen dick. Also Spaghetti sind der Feind, oder was? Eigentlich schon, für Sportler ja eigentlich schon, und meiden ja alle. Aber auf der anderen Seite, vor ein paar Jahren war es Fett. Fett ist der Feind. Wenn du Fett isst, wirst du Fett. Klingt ja aber auch einleuchtender, ehrlich gesagt. Wenn du die Wahl hast, also wenn du... Wogegen wenn du eine Spaghetti isst, wirst du schlank wie eine Spaghetti, das denkt man ja. Und man denkt auch, wenn man cholesterinhaltige Dinge isst, erhöht sich der Cholesterinspiegel. Und im Buch steht, das ist gar nicht der Fall. Und ich denke mir, ja klar, warum sollte das der Fall sein? Nicht, weil man etwas automatisch isst, wird man ja zu diesem Ding. Du willst ja nicht zu einem Ei, wenn du ein Ei isst. Da hat aber jemand richtig was gelernt diese Woche, Stefan. Ja, aber genau, das klingt gerade, du stellst es bewusst ja gerade da als etwas sehr Offensichtliches. Du siehst es durch den Kakao, ja. Du siehst es durch den Kakao, aber du willst ja nicht zum Kakao, wenn du Kakao bist. Was ich damit meine ist, der Cholesterinspiegel erhöht sich ja nicht zwangsläufig, nur weil Cholesterin ist, was alle Wissenschaftler bis dato immer dachten. Wo sind denn Späße jetzt? Ja, also ich bin entwaffnet. Wo sind deine bissigen Kommentare jetzt? Du, wie ist der Appetit vergangen? Ich bin völlig entwaffnet. Nee, eben nicht. Das ist ja genau das Gegenteil von dem, was ich will. Ach, verdammt, sorry. Appetit sollst du jetzt haben. Entschuldigung, ja, ich werde mir schön was reinessen. Esse mal einen schönen Snickers heute oder sowas. Ja, wobei das glaube ich nicht, was ich meine mit In Defense of Food. Naja, spannendes Buch, kann ich nur empfehlen, bin noch nicht durch. Also vielleicht ist noch mit einem Sternchen daran, diese Empfehlung. Vielleicht kommt noch ein Twist. Vielleicht kommt noch ein Plot-Twist und dann irgendwann so, oh, ich habe gerade zwei Wochen nach diesem Buch nicht weitergeschrieben. ihr glaubt nicht, was mir passiert ist. Ich habe mich so ernährt, wie ich es geschrieben habe, und ich bin fett. Ein unferter Fettsack. Hier ist ein Bild von mir, über vier Seiten. Und hier war das Bild von vor zwei Wochen. Seht ihr das? Seht ihr den Unterschied? Fetty Mac Fettson. Ich glaube, ich habe kompletten Quatsch erzählt. Sorry, sorry. Fang hier nochmal von vorne an. Also, esst kein Fett. Einfach. Das ist die Erklärung. Dann geht eine ganz andere Abhandlung los. Wir brauchen mehr Twists auch in Sachbüchern. Die Ehrlichkeit. Klingt ganz schön überzeugend, oder? Aber in Wahrheit ist es ganz anders. Und dann kommt eine zweite Hälfte, das ist einfach anders. Ich habe damals schon gemerkt, dass ich nicht gut mit Fakten bin und mit sowas wie Journalismus oder Wahrheit, weil damals gab es mal in der Schule mussten wir eine Wegbeschreibung machen, das war in der Grundschule, irgendwie so erste Klasse am Gymnasium, war das die Aufgabe, Wegbeschreibungen und meine Wegbeschreibung war lächerlich. Ich habe nicht den kürzesten Weg beschrieben zum einen, aus irgendeinem Grund und habe immer sowas geschrieben wie, hier könnte man links gehen, aber Achtung, das ist der ganz falsche Weg. Da hinten, ihr glaubt nicht, was ihr da vorfindet, und habt dann so Dinge erfunden, und am Ende gab es, glaube ich, meine bis dato schlechteste Note, irgendwie eine Vier oder sowas. Journalismus vier. Noch nie eine Vier, nee, in Wegbeschreibungen. Das war ein eigenes Fach? Nee, Deutsch war das Fach. Journalismus? Deutsch war das Fach, aber die Aufgabe war die Wegbeschreibung. Und dann habe ich einfach nur vier bekommen. Und dann war ich wirklich sauer. Aber da habe ich schon damals gemerkt, das ist nicht das, was ich will. Ich will nichts mit der Wahrheit zu tun haben. Ich bin in den so pragmatischen Dingen nicht gut. Ich habe eigentlich rückblickend in der Schule immer versucht zu bescheissen. Ja? Ich habe immer versucht zu betrügen. das war immer mein erster Ansatz. Und ich habe zum Beispiel auch mal, da hatten wir dann so Reizwortgeschichten, weil du jetzt gerade sagst, wie unglaublich kreativ du damals schon warst und ja, kein Talent, ja, du warst so wahnsinnig fantasievoll und da bist du gerade wirklich schon abgezeichnet. Ja, ja, okay. Bei mir war es anders und wir hatten Reizwortgeschichte, also du kriegst vier Begriffe, ich glaube, das habe ich dir aber schon mal erzählt, du kriegst vier Begriffe und musst daraus eine Geschichte machen und ich habe...
Wir haben so schon mal welche vorgelesen hier.
Und ich habe mir vorgenommen, ich habe am Tag davor eine Folge X-Faktor das Unfassbare gesehen und dachte mir, ich schreibe einfach die Geschichte.
Eins zu eins. Und habe dann die Reizworte bekommen, passen nicht dem Ansatz dazu, ich habe trotzdem einfach die Geschichte geschrieben und im letzten Satz irgendwie so ganz dumm untergebracht und total beschissen und habe eine Vier gekriegt, dafür, dass ich einfach eine Geschichte nacherzählt habe, die ich davor im Fernsehen gesehen habe. Ich habe das auch gemacht, mit Gänsehautbuch, was ich gelesen habe. Ja, eins zu eins abgeschrieben. Aber irgendwann sind mir die Synonyme für ihm lief ein kalter Schauer den Rücken hinunter ausgegangen. Und es war so eine Horror, so eine blutige Horrorgeschichte, aber irgendwie in der vierten Klasse. Und Carina, weiß ich noch, Carina hat zehn Seiten geschrieben über Schlösschen und Prinzesschen. Und ich habe dann so eine blutige Horrorgeschichte, weil ich davor von R.L. Stine Gänsehaut gelesen habe. Ihm lief ein kalter Schauer den Rücken runter, ihm lief es eiskalt den Rücken runter, er hatte Gänsehaut. Ihn erfasste ein kalter, sein Herz setzte für einen Schlag aus, gibt es noch. Oh, sehr gut, ja. Ihm blieb der Atem weg, er stockte. Ihm wurde eiskalt, ihmhm wurde anders. Ihm wurde ganz anders. Er bekam es mit der Angst zu tun. Ja. Ihm fröstelte vor Angst. Die Angst stand ihm ins Gesicht. Er wurde blass wie eine Leiche. Ja. Leichenblass. Er fing an zu zittern, oh ja, wo wir bereit sind mit den Verben, schaudern, er fing an zu schlottern, Panik schoss, Panikpunkt, er bekam Panik. Die gesamte Geschichte! Er ging in sein Zimmer in einem Hotel, in dem er noch nie war, eröffnete den Schrank und daraus schoss eine Leiche. Und ab dann, 18 Seiten nur noch, Beschreibung, ihm stieg die Angst bis zum Kopfschnute. Nein, ehrlich, ihm lief ein eiskalter Schauer den Rücken hinunter. Um es anders auszudrücken. Seine Glieder wurden steif vor Angst. Ich glaube, ihr habt es noch nicht ganz verstanden. Panik in seinen Augen, Panik. In seinen Ohren, Panik, seinen Mund, überall Panik. Überall ein P im Gesicht, er hat ein P im Gesicht. Und einfach wirklich 20 Seiten und dann Ende. Ja, eins. Eins minus. Sehr blumig. Eins minus, genau, weil zu brutal. Müssen wir über irgendwas sprechen, was letzte Woche wieder vorgefallen ist? Du hast schon wieder diesen Blick auf der ... Naja, wenn du jetzt über den Skandal reden möchtest, der im Raum steht, der sich anbarnt.
Ja, ich will den Skandal im Raum sprechen.
Ja, das Podcast-UFO steht erneut vor dem Abgrund. Es muss man sagen, die Intervalle werden aber größer. Ja, das muss man sagen, ja, die Intervalle, mit denen wir vor dem Ruin... Vor dem oft finanziellen Ruin stehen oder kriminellen Ruin, auf jeden Fall Ruin, auf eine Art Ruin. Ich würde sagen, sie kommen seltener, aber heftiger. Ja, genau. Die Einschläge kommen nicht unbedingt näher. Jetzt sind wir schon wieder in so einem Synonym-Ding gefangen. Aber schwerer. Aber es kommen schwerere Einschläge. Woran nimmst du bei Einschlägen eigentlich immer? Bomben, oder? Ja. Oder so ein Stein, der von so einem Katapult an so ein Katapult so direkt vor einem landet. Die Einsteige kommen näher. Ja. Ich will das wohl bei so schlafenden Hunden wecken. Welche Hunde denkst du da? Eine Dogge. Gefährliche Hunde? Oder eher so nervige Hunde? Mit so einem Stachelhalsband, so ein Rottwein. Dinge, die dich anfallen können. Ja, wo man sagt, weck den mal lieber nicht. Ich hatte mal, der dachte, man meint dann nervige Hunde, die am Anfang die ganze Zeit bellen. Und schlafende Hunde wecken ist einfach primär, danach wird es halt nervig. Aber danach wird es gefährlich. Aber ich finde es interessant, weil jeder interpretiert die ja anders. Oder es wird süss. Es wird ja nie erklärt. Es gibt ja so selbsterklärende Sprichworte. Aber vielleicht mag man ja Hunde und das wird süss. Ja. Oh, bloss gerne schlafende Hunde weg. Warum denn? Nee, doch. Oh, ich will so gerne schlafende Hunde weg. Ja. Kommt man doch an, wie viele, ne? Also es ist ja oft in so Sprichwörtern nicht ganz klar, wie viele jetzt tatsächlich. Ja. So zehn, selbst zehn süße Hunde sind zu viele. Woran denkst du bei Eselsbrücke? Einen Esel, der über eine Brücke geht. Ja? Ja. Ich denke über eine Br eine Brücke aus Esel. Ein riesiger Esel. Aber du wolltest was sagen. Ja, die Tour begleitend, die Tour Ankündigung begleitend haben wir ja Fotos veröffentlicht. Du erinnerst dich? Ich habe kaum noch Erinnerungen daran. Wir haben Fotos gemacht für die Tour und wir haben auch viele tolle Fotos bekommen von euch, die schon die Tourkarten
bekommen haben. Und dann haben wir Fotos gemacht, kleines Fotoshooting, nett, haben dafür extra Kostüme bestellt. Und kannst du noch mal kurz sagen, von wo die Kostüme kamen? Ich habe die aus Wien bestellt, aus dem schönen Wien. Die schönsten Kostüme gibt es natürlich in Wien, die Leibatzen Leiber. Oh, Kostüme sind Leiber. Und ja, man muss sagen, es ist eine alte Kostümmanufaktur, weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall ist es eine Kostüm-Dynastie aus Wien. Welche anderen Projekte haben die schon betreut? Zum Beispiel The Favourite mit Emma Stone, von und mit Emma Stone, eigentlich nur mit. Von Jorgos Latimos. Jorgos Latimos. Latimos. Latimos. Und das sind ganz tolle Sachen, die die gemacht haben. Game of Thrones vielleicht auch, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Sie haben sehr viele alte barocke Kostüme. In Wien hat die wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie jeder irgendwo im Keller noch rumstehen. Ja. Und bei denen haben wir die gekauft, bestellt. Also geliehen für den Zeitraum und haben denen eine Summe XY überwiesen, damit wir die bekommen. Gerade war das ein bisschen schwierig, die kamen dann erst nicht an, dann kam sie doch, war alles ein bisschen schwierig. Jetzt habe ich bei der Post Österreich angemeldet aus Gründen, weil ich dachte, dann kann ich das woanders hinschicken. Hat alles nicht funktioniert, jetzt kriege ich sehr viel Post von der Post Österreich. Andere Geschichte. Jedenfalls kam es dann zu dem Moment, und ich muss sagen, ich habe das schon auch gut organisiert, habe das auch vor allem in die Hand genommen. Aber du bist da einfach talentiert, was das eigentlich ist. Aber ich bin wahnsinnig, ich habe auch als Kind schon sehr viel organisiert. Da gab es auch mal eine Klausur damals, da musste ich so organisieren und da war ich schon so wahnsinnig gut drin. So, jedenfalls habe ich gesagt, nee, das Paket zurückschicken, tue ich nicht auchorentin. Da hast du wirklich auch mal auf dich selber geachtet, weil... Da habe ich auch mal auf den Tisch gehauen. Ich nutze dich aus, ich nutze deine Gutgläubigkeit, deine Frohnatur aus. Das sagen nicht nur wir, sondern auch Außenstehende, Objektive, die uns beobachten, sagen, du nutzt meine Frohnatur aus. Richtig. Deine Energie, dein jugendlichen Esprit, deine Spritzigkeit, Leichtsinn kann man viel sagen, nutze ich aus, deine Naivität, deine Begeisterungsfreude. Und dann hast du gesagt, nein, du schickst das zurück, weil du hast dir viel, viel Arbeit gemacht, danke. Gerne. Und hast dann, sag ich mal, das Paket in den Bereich unseres Zweiergespanns gerückt, der vielleicht nicht so ganz zuverlässig ist, problemanfälliger, und es war meine Aufgabe, diese Kostüme zurückzuschicken. So, da, also hier kann man, hier normalerweise wäre hier eine Schwarzblende, man würde in die Werbung gehen, ja. Oder man kennt das ja auch bei alten Kinderserien, wo keineerien, wo in Amerika offensichtlich mehr Werbung war als in Deutschland. Richtig, ja. Und man ist als Deutscher gewohnt, dass offenbar Schwarzblende manchmal kommen und danach geht die Szene sofort genau da weiter. Ja. Und ich dachte immer, es wäre normal, es wäre ein Thing, aber ist es nicht. Das ist nur, weil in Amerika häufiger die Werbeintervalle kürzer sind. Ja. Ah, ist schon interessant. Naja, was ist passiert nach der Schwarzblende? Geht's genau da weiter? Du solltest das wegbringen. Ich hab erst mal eine Woche gewartet. So, da fängt es an, weil jeder Tag kostet sehr viel Geld im, ich will nicht sagen wie viel, aber in einem immens hohen, wie gesagt, es sind Kostüme, die hat auch Emma Stone schon getragen. Richtig, schaut dich das Favorite an, tolle Kostüme, tolle Tauspielerin. Amore Osra bekommen für Kostümen, meine ich. Jedenfalls, ganz, ganz teure Kostüme, die hat auch Emma Stone schon getragen. Richtig, die sind teuer. Schaut dich The Favorite an, teule Kostüme, die eine Tauspielerin. Am Wochen Oscar bekommen für Kostüme, meine ich. Jedenfalls, ganz, ganz teure Kostüme. Warum wartest du eine Woche, bevor du die losschickst? Ja, weil ich nicht wusste genau, wie das geht. Das ist ein riesiges Paket und eine Packstation, dafür ist es zu gross. Aber warum löst das Problem nicht, indem du was aktiv dagegen tust? Warum wartest du eine Woche? Stefan, ich bin ein sehr fauler Mensch, der Probleme vor sich her schiebt und das Problem ist, dass mein momentaner Lebensentwurf diese negative Seite von mir massiv... Wie schön wäre das Wort momentaner? Ganz kurz. Mein momentaner? Ja, ist doch viel schöner als momentaner. Auch hier. Podcast-UFO-Hörer... Feel free to use it. Sprachen entwickeln sich. Mein momenteller Lebensentwurf diese negative Seite von mir massiv verstärkt. Denn ich pendle ja immer zwischen Hamburg und Köln. Und das ermöglicht mir, die Kölner Probleme in Köln zu lassen und die Hamburger Probleme in Hamburg zu lassen. Du hast aber auch in beiden Orten zu wenig Zeit, um die Probleme anzufassen. Genau. Ich bin immer da, wo meine Probleme nicht sind. Wenn ich in Hamburg bin, denke ich, ach ja, das Paket ist ja in Köln, kann ich ja gerade nicht machen.
Wenn ich in Köln bin, sage ich, ich fahre ja übermorgen schon wieder nach Hamburg, dann mache ich es halt nächste Woche. Und so kann ich jedes Problem auf beliebig lange Weise hinausschicken. Eines Tages dachte ich mir dann, gut, der Stefan hat sich so viel Mühe gegeben und dann check ich's ab und habe mir dann erstmal so einen Zettel rausgelassen in Hamburg, um dann in Köln das Paket loszuschicken. Du hast also dann die Probleme auf beide Städte aufgeteilt? Richtig. Damit dich das Problem auf den Schultern einer Stadt liegt. Richtig. Und habe es abgeschickt und zwei Wochen und denke mir, gut, hast du gut gemacht, Stefan ist bestimmt stolz auf dich, von dem kommt bestimmt noch meine Aufmutter in der Nachricht, danke, dass du es übernommen hast an der Stelle, so wie ich mich immer dafür bedanke, dass du es machst. Was kam stattdessen von dir zwei Wochen später? Die Beschwerde, Mahnung. Wo, und ich muss sagen, als die Kostüme zunächst nicht kamen von denen, habe ich die ein bisschen angeschissen. weil es war bereits Fotograf, Licht, Assistenz, Maske, alles bestellt, alles von mir organisiert und dann kamen diese scheiss Kostüme nicht an, obwohl die mir das zugesichert haben. Dann habe ich uns einen hohen Betrag an Geld in Schädigungssumme rausgehandelt. Weil du so hartnäckig warst. Und die waren, genau, ich habe
die angerufen und gesagt, das geht ja wohl nicht.
Dann waren die aber patzig. Ich weiß nicht, ob die patzig waren,
weil die diesen Wiener Dialekt
drauf haben oder weil es einfach, weil die
wirklich patzig waren. Weiß ich nicht. Ist auch ein bisschen
dasselbe. Dann
hast du es verbaselt,
verwient. Ich habe es verfrebelt.
Du hast es verfrebelt mit dem Paket
und jetzt plötzlich war ich in dieser unangenehmen, hatte immer noch diesen unangenehmen Hochstatus. Was war passiert überhaupt? Das Paket kam nicht an. Das Paket kam nicht an in Wien. Ja, das Paket kam nicht an und dann haben die mich angerufen und man muss sagen, das war jetzt, ihr wisst ihr wie lange das die Fotos schon gibt, die haben mich gestern angerufen. Es ist halt das Problem, dass wir durch die Fotos den Beweis erbracht haben, dass das Paket überhaupt angekommen ist. Und das hätten wir sagen können, wir haben es nie bekommen. Mit Fotos ist es natürlich immer schwierig, da kann man schlecht lügen. Und ja, Paket ist weg. Das ist aber eine interessante Frage, wer ist jetzt schuld? Weil ich habe es abgegeben. Ich habe gesagt, ja, also meine, er ist echt gesagt, der Anruf hat mich nicht gewundert, um ehrlich zu sein. Um total ehrlich zu sein, hat mich der Anruf nicht im Ansatz irritiert.
Du bist wie der Vater von einem Kind, wo jede Woche der Rektor anruft. Und irgendwann sagst du, ja, Herr Breusen, was gibt es hier? Da habe ich damit fest gerechnet, mit diesem Anruf.
Ich hätte schon gesehen, Wiener vorbei.
Ich bin drangegangen, grüsste See, hau Wien, this is Cologne calling. Dann hat er mir gesagt, ja, this is Vienna calling. Wir haben kein Paket bekommen. Nach ihrer letzten E-Mail, wo sie sich sehr beschwert haben über unser Timing, höchst verwunderlich, weil es sollte am nächsten Tag direkt zurückgeschickt werden. Und da habe ich gesagt, das hat mein Kollege übernommen, habe direkt die Schuld abgeschoben. Keinen Namen genannt? Doch, Adresse und Namen. Das hat direkt mein Kollege Florian den Will übernommen. Habe direkt auch einen Link zu dem Bequerel-Artikel geschickt, zu Google Maps, zu deinem Haus, zu meinem Facebook-Account, wo ich Bilder poste, wie ich privat diese Kostüme habe. Wie du privat mit dem Kostüm auch feiern gehst, etc. Genau. Höchst unangenehm, und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich kümmere mich darum, ja, wir hätten gerne die Sendungsnummer, bitte. Dann wollten sie die Sendung, alles super patzig, will ich in so einem passiv-aggressiven Wiener-Ton-Fall, und man kann denen auch nicht böse sein. Nee. So, man denkt sich auch, Aber man denkt sich auch ihr habt so schön da unten in Wien. Ja, geht doch schön in Burgtheater. Geht doch ins Burgtheater, zieht euch eure Ästen ein bisschen Kaiserschmarrn, haupten Leib und Talk. So, aber das ist doch immer schlechter mit mir. So, und dann habe ich mich an Froting gewendet, mit der Nachricht, ja, ist ist nicht verschickt worden, oder? Machen wir uns nichts vor. Du hast gesagt, du hast es verschickt, aber nicht, wo man das machen würde normalerweise, sondern. Ja, ich habe es in einem Kiosk verschickt. So, Kiosk, bist du bescheuert? Das sind kostbare Barockkostüme, originale Barockkostüme, Mozart, Amadeus Wolfgang, könnte in diesem Kostüm gesteckt haben schon mal. Ja, ist richtig, wenn auch unwahrscheinlich, aber ich habe wie gesagt den Zettel mir geholt in der Post, habe den Zettel ausgefüllt, auf das Paket geklebt und am Kiosk abgegeben. Warum diese Verkettung von verschiedenen Läden? Weil es ein riesiges fucking Paket ist und ich damit nicht durch die halbe Stadt laufen wollte, sondern lieber den Zettel zu mir hole, um dann das Paket nur nebenan den Kiosk zu bringen. Und dann heisst du ja, welche Sendungsnummer und ich so, wie, welche Sendungsnummer, ich gebe dem Geld, ich gebe dem Geld, der nimmt das Paket und dann nicken wir uns zu und wir wissen beide, dass der keine Steuern zahlt, dass das niemand, dass der das irgendwie sein Kumpel hat. Und wir wissen beide, dass er jetzt ein kostbares, schweres Paket bei sich stehen hat, wo er weiß, der Typ, der wollte nicht mal den Zettel haben mit der Sendungsnummer, der interessiert sich einen Scheiss dafür, ob das ankommt oder nicht. Und dann erinnere ich mich, dass er mir noch einen Zettel gegeben hat. Aber ich dachte, halt einen Kassenzettel. Und dann dachte ich mir, habe ich den Zettel aufgehoben? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Und dann habe ich dir schon geschrieben, ja, ich hätte den Zettel, nicht vergiss es, ja, mach deine Stefan-Magic, es wird schon. Und da habe ich noch eine Stunde diesen scheiß Zettel gesucht, meinen ganzen Schreibtisch durchwühlt und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr dieses Gefühl kennt, aber so dieses man, es gibt ein Problem und dann hat man die Schuld. Schuld ich, schuld ich, schuld ich, schuld ich, schuld ich, ganz lange, schuld ich, oh nein, bei mir ist immer schuld du, schuld er, oh nein, schuld er, oh nein, schuld ich, schuld ich, schuld. Und dann passiert etwas und du findest diesen winzigen kleinen Zettel. Ja, aber sorry, das löst ja die Schuld nicht auf. Also es gibt ja wenig Gegenstände, die weniger wertvoll sind als ein Kassenzettel. Aber in dem Moment war dieses Schuld ich, Schuld ich, Schuld ich, ah nee, Schuld, Post, Schuld, Post, Schuld, Post. Ja, last weg. Weil ich habe diesen Zettel gefunden und ja, ich habe den Zettel gefunden, ich habe alles drauf, dass ich abgegeben habe, wann Sendungsnummer, ich bin raus aus diesem Thema, ich sage gerne vor Gericht aus, wir bringen das Ganze gerne vor das Wiener Staatsgericht, können wir gerne machen, dann ziehen wir uns und für den Gerichtsterminichen wir uns fucking barocke Kostüme aus, um in Wien vor das Gericht zu gehen.
Ja, also ehrlich gesagt, das Problem ist nicht behoben.
Ne, also ...
Aber ich hab keine Schuld ...
Nee, doch.
Entschuldigung, ich bin ja nicht verantwortlich, was die Post macht.
Du hättest doch, aber die werden ja nicht die Post verklagen können, die werden uns verklagen, uns armen Mann.
Aber wir können ja nichts dafür.
Nee, du hast es nicht versichert. Und ich denke natürlich, soll ich ihm doch sagen, dass er das ein per Einschreiben oder versichert schicken soll? Soll ich ihm das sagen? Nee, der wird das schon hinkriegen. Dass du das unversichert, die Barockkostüme, einfach mit dem billigsten Plaket auf dem du bekommen kannst, versichst und dann wegschickst an einem Kiosk, war mir wirklich nicht bewusst. Nee, aber jetzt mal im Ernst. Bin ich wirklich noch in der Schuld? Ja. Weil ich habe das doch abgeschickt. Ja, aber nicht versichert. Wenn es weg ist, ist es weg und dann müssen wir für diese Kostüme aufkommen. Und die werden bestimmt im fünfstelligen Bereich kosten. Was? Ja, wir sind Barockkostüme von The Favourite, Emma Stone hat da reingeschwitzt, John. Wie sollen wir das bezahlen? Und dann erklärst du das unseren Patreon-Eigreuten. Dann gehe ich aber zu dem Kiosk und sag mal, Kollege, jetzt pass mal auf, mein Lieber, jetzt freut mich. Und er dreht sich um, oh, ich habe sie noch gar nicht erwartet, mit seinem Federhut und seinem Barockoutfit. Hallo, Sire! Wo sind meine Kostüme? Ich weiß nicht, mich dünkt, als hätte ich sie das letzte Mal gesehen, als sie meinen Laden betraten. Ah, ach scheiße. Doch, jetzt schuld ich, schuld ich, schuld ich, schuld er. Jetzt ist der angegegen Moment, jetzt wieder schuld ich, schuld ich, schuld ich. Ich weiss nicht, ehrlich gesagt, vor Gericht. Nein, dann ziehen wir vor Gericht von mir aus, was soll's. Ja, erstmal vor das Wiener Staatsgericht ziehen.. Aber nur für den Fall, könnt ihr noch ein paar Tickets kaufen da draußen? Weil es kann sein, dass Gerichtskosten auf uns zukommen. Ich hab deine Ahnung, das wäre echt nicht verstanden. Unsere Tour läuft sehr gut. Vielen Dank, hat aber sehr gut funktioniert. Ehrlich gesagt, vielen, vielen Dank für alle Leute, die Tour ist ausverkauft. Geil, also mega krass. Das ist eine grosse Tour, grosse Locations. Das ist unfassbar toll von euch, dass ihr da nochmal kommt. Es ist super krass, wir freuen uns sehr und auch nochmal ganz kurz an alle, die sich ärgern, dass sie keine Karten mehr bekommen haben.
Es ist natürlich schade, es gibt nur eine limitierte Anzahl. Manchmal könnt ihr unter Hashtag Pufo Live noch Leute finden, die Karten verkaufen.
Hashtag Pufo Live.
Ich freue mich auf alle, die wir sehen auf der Tour und es wird grossartig, wir fahren wieder, wir machen uns wieder auf den Weg.
Wir steigen wieder ins Auto, im Zug und haben einen Rucksack dabei.
Da ist ein Brot drin, da ist ein Apfel drin, da ist eine Flasche Wasser drin und dann kann es losgehen. Ich bin ein bisschen froh, dass wir jetzt keinen Wien-Termin, ehrlich gesagt, haben. Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind gerade nicht so gern gesehen in der Stadt. Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, die haben viel Einfluss in der Stadt auch, so diese Kostümleute. Ja, ich glaube, lächerlich. Man sagt ja, dass in den Städten, also dass die höchsten Gebäude einer Stadt traditionell immer Aussagen, wofür diese Stadt steht. Beispiel Frankfurt, die hohen Bankengebäude, das ist eine Bankerstadt. Wien, die hohen Kostümlädengebäude, die Staatsoper zum Beispiel, ist wohl bestimmt eines der höchsten Gebäude,
der Stephansdom. Das ist eine sehr traditionelle,
kulturliebende Stadt,
wo die Kostüme eine grosse Rolle spielen.
Deswegen glaube ich, hast du recht. Die haben einen grossen Einfluss.
New York
ist irgendwie
auch eine Stadt mit allem. Das neue World Trade Center
steht für
Aufbruch und neue
Progressivität.
Oder der Buschke Liefer für unplatzierte, seltsam speziell platzierte Reichtum. Komm, jetzt wieder dein Rant über Gebäude, die dir nicht gefallen. Bist du noch Architektur, Stefan, eigentlich, oder hat sich das wieder komplett? Nee, ich wusste mir das jetzt mir völlig egal. Hat sich das komplett erledigt? Komplett egal. Ey, ich habe jetzt wirklich wieder so einen neuen youtube was sagt man fable fable ja fable neuen youtube fable gefunden du bist nicht so ganz überzeugt nehm ich an die go with it und und zwar gibt es leute die bauen selber jet triebwerke für für miniaturflugzeuge Ja, unter anderem oder auch einfach gar nicht um was zu bewegen, sondern einfach nur um diese Turbine zu bauen. Die steht dann fest auf ihrem Schreibtisch, aber das ist ja schon mal sehr schwer, die zu bauen, das Luft vorne rein und dann wird die Luft komprimiert und dann kommt der Treibstoff rein und dann, damit es überhaupt läuft, muss man schon mal viel Gedanken sich machen, damit das Ding überhaupt läuft und nicht einfach sofort wieder abgewirkt wird, weil dann muss genau die Balance und es ist so interessant, weil die dann auch so, so lang, es ist einfach toll, die dann zuzugucken und dann erklären die genau, wie es funktioniert und dann müssen die das Ding bauen und dann müssen die Löcher bohren, weil der Treibstoff genau das Verhältnis haben muss und dann einer einerseits so abstrakte Begriffe wie Treibstoffverhältnisse, aber auf der anderen Seite ist der Unterschied, ob du drei Löcher in das Metallstück gebohrt hast oder vier. Und dann sagen die, oh, jetzt ist das Verhältnis falsch, noch ein Loch reinbohren. Dann machen sie es nochmal und das ist toll. Und am Ende läuft das Teil und es passiert halt nichts, aber es ist trotzdem cool. Ja, ich verstehe das. Sehr special interest, aber es ist auch super. Ja. Es ist total toll, wie gut dokumentiert Dinge mittlerweile sind. Es ist so krass und vor allem dann so eine Tür zu so einer neuen Welt. Es gibt halt nicht nur zwei, drei Videos, sondern zwei, drei hunderttausend Videos. Es gibt allein hundert Kanäle, die sich nur damit beschäftigen, ich baue meine eigene Turbine, wie geht das? Und die haben alle hunderte Videos. Und ich glaube, solche Leute bringen auch die Welt voran, weil diese Leute haben begrenzte Möglichkeiten. Gut, ob man jetzt solche Verbrennungsmotoren noch in der Zukunft so braucht, aber vielleicht ist es nicht. Nee, ich meine, vielleicht kriegen die das hin, das Energiesparen dahin zu bekommen, zum Beispiel. Oder sowas. Weil die haben ja eine Ressourcenknappheit, eine Geldknappheit oft auch. Das sind ja auch Privatleute.
Ich habe ja jetzt in meinem Technikverständnis einen absoluten Meilenstein begangen, denn ich habe mein Schloss repariert. Zu Hause kam sehr schlecht in mein Haustürschloss rein. Ich musste es fast aufbrechen. Und mir wurde Grafit empfohlen und ich habe es mit Grafit gemacht und es ist ein Traum. Grafit. Es ist unvorstellbar. Also stell dir mal vor, ein Schloss, Schlüssel rein, Schloss umdrehen, maximal wenig Widerstand. Du kannst es dir gar nicht glauben. Ich kann es mir immer noch nicht glauben. Jedes Mal, wenn ich meine Tür aufsperre, denke ich mir, das kann nicht sein. Noch nie hatte ich etwas, das so sanft, zart. Aber auch so einfach reparierbar ist, offensichtlich, mit der perfekten ... Warum Graphit? Das ist Graphitpulver und das habe ich so auf den Schlüssel gestreut und dann mit dem Schlüssel reingesteckt, rumgedeckt und es war ... Graphitpulver heißt aber nicht, du hast einen Bleistift angespitzt. Das geht auch. Hat auch jemand geschrieben, wenn man wirklich keinen Graphitpulver hat, kann man seinen Schlüssel mit Bleistift anmalen und dann ginge das auch. Und es ist ein Traum. Hast du jetzt einen Eimer Graphitpulver bei dir rumstehen noch? Ich habe so einen Rödler und hat schön über die Hand geballert erstmal und habe ich auch nicht mehr abbekommen. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich müsste Magnet nehmen, Magnet ist Graphit, geht nicht, aber ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich gut, da muss eigentlich Magnet steuern. Aber und dann dachte ich mir erstmal, wow, technische Sachen können sehr geschmeidig laufen. Also sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr geschmeidig. Eigentlich ist es auch völlig, also es ist so naiv von uns beiden, handwerklich so komplett gar kein Interesse zu haben. Wir haben viele Interessen, seltsame spezielle Interessen, Düsentriebwerke, Magnete, Kram, aber wirklich anwendbare Interessen sind doch das Logischste der Welt. Ein grundhandwertiges Interesse zu haben, ist doch das Sinnvollste überhaupt.
Ich habe so viele Probleme, aber jetzt sind wir beide auch nicht wahnsinnig blöde, sondern ich glaube, wir können uns viele Dinge dann auch erklären oder sowas, weil viele Dinge sind ja auch einfach selbsterklärend.
Zum Beispiel habe ich neulich meine Gastherme, ging nicht mehr richtig und dann war da, ich verstehe nicht wofür diese ganzen Dinge sind ja auch einfach selbsterklärend. Zum Beispiel habe ich neulich meine Gastherme, ging nicht mehr richtig, und dann war da, ich verstehe nicht wofür diese ganzen Dinge sind, Wasserdruck runter. Und dann ist das, das war halt nicht in einem grünen Bereich mehr, sondern diese Nadel hat angezeigt, zu wenig Wasserdruck. Und dann habe ich halt einen Wasserschlauch genommen und das an diese Gastherme gemacht und dachte mir, also man musste sich halt so ein bisschen von dem Gefühl befreien, dass man gerade an einer Gastherme was macht. Aber das klingt alles gefährlich und so. Und dann denkt er aber auch, ja gut, das wird ja nicht explodieren, wenn da jetzt ein Junge ein bisschen rumrödelt. Das kann ja nicht sein. Das klingt wie so eine Schlagzeile, Junge rödelt an Gaslightung rum und tötet 50 Menschen im Block. Ich denke mir halt, die Dinge werden nicht so konstruiert sein. Ich habe nicht so viel Vertrauen in die Menschheit, dass sie so konstruiert sind, dass ich da jetzt nichts grandios kaputt mache. Und du hast wirklich hundertprozentig recht, weil ich habe mir das alles angeguckt und ich dachte mir auch, ich will mehr technische Sachen machen.
Und ich fange an und ich habe zwei Projekte, die ich konkret angehen will.
Und das eine hat mit Strom zu tun, das andere hat mit Temperatur zu tun und ich will mir jetzt einen Thermometer kaufen und ich will so selber Messungen machen und Experimente machen.
Ich will zum Beispiel gucken, wie viel Strom mein Kühlschrank verbraucht und wann und wie, weil ich habe eine und ich will,
dass mir niemand darauf antwortet, weil ich habe Bock darauf, es selber rauszufinden und wenn ihr die Antwort wisst, bitte schreibt mir auf gar keinen Fall und zwar will ich eine folgende Frage beantwortet haben, wie lange muss ein Kühlschrank ausgeschaltet sein, damit man Strom spart? Weil ein Kühlschrank hat ja eine gewisse Temperatur und die ist ja, man braucht ja mehr Energie auf eine Temperatur zu kommen, als die Temperatur zu halten. Das heißt, wenn du den Stecker ziehst und dann wärmt er auf und dann steckst du ihn direkt wieder rein, hast du insgesamt, obwohl der Kühlschrank eine Weile aus war, wahrscheinlich Strom mehr verbraucht. Wie lange muss man ja aus sein, damit man insgesamt Strom spart? Weil ich fahre ja immer nach Hamburg und ich mache immer meinen Kühlschrank aus. Das ist, glaube ich, eine gute Idee. Und ich bin halt dann ein paar Tage weg. Das ist, glaube ich, zu wenig, ja. Und das ist dann die Frage, wie viel Energie... Und das ist ja ganz einfach. Du musst ja nur so ein Ding kaufen, das misst, wie viel Strom da fließt, durch dieses Stecker. Und dann musst du da halt einfach experimentieren, einfach zählen. So, und das will ich jetzt machen als Projekt, dasselbe herauszufinden, schreibt mir nichts. Ich will das selber herausfinden. Das ist nicht so schwer. Es ist überhaupt nicht schwer. Es ist nicht so schwer herauszufinden, wie lange, also wie viel der Strom du spart um Ausschalten. Aber das Hochfahren ist halt schwierig zu checken, oder? Naja, ich kann den ja messen lassen, während der eingesteckt ist. Ich brauche dann halt nur irgendein Gerät, das die Messung auch dokumentiert. Also am liebsten hätte ich am Computer dann so einen Graphen, der mir genau zeigt, wann wie viel Strom verbraucht. Und dann errechne ich es schon. Ich bin ein Fan von Graphen. Alter, das ist so geil. Damals bei der Bahncard habe ich mir auch immer Graphen gemacht. Ich habe mir alte Formeln erstellt und habe die Bahncards gegeneinander ausgedacht. Ja, das war richtig. Ich habe genau geguckt, an welcher Fahrt im Jahr lohnt sich die Bahncard 50. Und es war so eine knappe Entscheidung, dass es ein bisschen unbefriedigend war, die Bahncard 50 zu nehmen, aber es war dann doch die Bahncard 50. Und vor allem wirklich an alle, die jetzt vielleicht auch in der Schule sitzen, etwas, wo man nie sagen kann, das braucht man nicht, ist einfach Mathe. Mathe ist das Beste, was es gibt. Und diese Grafenrechnung, ihr denkt euch, das ist beschissen, aber es ist einfach die Lösung. Oh, hast du geil. Es ist einfach, das ist einfach die Lösung. Ja, das macht Spaß. So funktioniert die Welt einfach. Und es ist einfach gut, du hast die Funktion von wie viel Geld, wie viel kosten Bahntickets durch Zeit, und dann kannst du einfach einsetzen, wann schneiden sich die beiden Linien, und es funktioniert halt wirklich. Du wärst so ein Tüftler, du müsstest so ein Raspberry Pi kaufen, diese selbstprogrammierbaren Computer. Nein, ich habe immer Angst, dass meine Geduld fehlt. Aber ich glaube, ich brauche einfache Dinge über einen langen Zeitraum. So jeden Tag die Messung aufschreiben. Das würde mir Spaß machen. Ich treibe jeden Tag die Messung auf und dann habe ich irgendwie nach zwei Wochen ohne viel Aufwand. Und ich werde das angehen, weil das Geile an solchen Projekten ist ja, es fängt leicht an, aber es kann ja beliebig kompliziert werden, weil verbraucht ein Kühlschrank an warmen Tagen mehr Strom, verbraucht ein Kühlschrank tagsüber mehr Strom als nachts. Und dann kann man sich überlegen, welche Messung, ist die Messung denn vertretbar? Also angenommen, ich habe jetzt in einer warmen Woche den Kühlschrank ausgemacht, ist es dann überhaupt repräsentierbar? Wenn wir noch enger befreundet wären... Bist du jetzt die Freundschaft, Gündig? Nee, würde ich jetzt auf den Status, auf dem wir jetzt sind, dann würde ich tatsächlich meine Bedenken äussern. Und würde mal fragen, privat geht's dir gut? Super, also toll. Nee, weil du dich jetzt so auf die Kühlschrankforschung... Ich habe ein erfülltes Privatleben an der Stelle, aber ich finde es, ich glaube, was ich an solchen Projekten interessant finde, ist, wenn man eine konkrete Frage hat. Ja, finde ich super. Weil dann lernt man sich Sachen selber an und ich werde das jetzt machen und bitte verlehrt mich den Spaß und gebt mir irgendwelche Antworten. Ich will es gar nicht wissen und ich halte euch auf dem
Laufenden, wie es läuft, weil vielleicht
denkt ihr euch, wenn ich in Urlaub fahre,
vielleicht sollte ich meinen Kühlschrank auch einfach ausschalten.
Das ist aber sehr praktikabel.
Ich finde das supergute Fragen und ich glaube, da liegen
auch noch mehr Fragen auch in der Ecke,
weil man muss
ja auch so kleine Sachen machen können, um jetzt die
Welt zu retten. Ich habe das Gefühl,
wir gehen unter, die Welt geht unter. Ich habe echt das Gefühl, jetzt kommt ein Hurricane auf uns zu, Leute. Das stimmt, ja. Das ist auch neu. Vorhin gab es halt Hurricanes. Aber auch ganz geil eigentlich. Geil! Auch ganz geil. Mega geil! Deswegen sage ich ja, noch ein bisschen Klimawandel und dann irgendwann Cut. Ja, ja, dann stopp. Wenn hier dieses L.A. Wetter ist, dieses immer, dann Cut, dann sagen, oh, jetzt ist Rauch genug, so, Deutschland ist, da reicht jetzt. Aber so lange noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen wärmer wäre schön, ein bisschen mehr Hurricanes, ein bisschen mehr. Das ist halt das Ding am Klima, man muss halt den genau richtigen Zeitpunkt treffen, aber halt schon 50 Jahre davor. Das ist ein Wann, das ist so wie so ein Tanker in den Hafen ein Pferd, so. Wir wollen genau, wir sollen so fünf Grad mehr, in Deutschland wäre geil. Geil. Da müsste man eigentlich schon noch die Kohlekraftwerke schon noch mal ein bisschen weiterlaufen. Aber ich glaube dann, wenn wir diesen Punkt erreichen, dass es hier geil ist immer, haben wir aber schon diesen Point of no return erreicht, dass dann das Weltklima kippt. Ja. Und mein Aquarium ist gekippt und ich kann euch sagen, wow, wow, wow. Übrigens ist ein Aquarium zu haben auch ein geiles Projekt, so biochemisch, weil du so viele Tests durchführen musst und so. Mir haben die Tests auch immer mehr Spaß gemacht als die Tiere eigentlich. Ja, das wäre tatsächlich mein Traum, kann ich jetzt mal sagen, wenn man irgendwer sagt, keine Ahnung, in Rente oder du gewinnst im Lotto. Ich würde mir gerne ein kleines Waldstück kaufen und da ein See anlegen. Ein See anlegen? Anlegen, ein grosses Loch graben und dann da irgendwie dann Wasser rein und dann gucken, welche Algen und welcher pH-Wert und wie krieg ich Sinn, dass da Tiere drin leben. Ich verstehe Seen nicht. Fände ich super spannend. Wieso, wenn du ein Lochgräbs ein grosses und da sehr viel Wasser reinmachst, sackt das nicht alles ab? Ja, genau das sind solche Fragen, mit denen
ich mich dann beschäftige. Du kannst doch nicht mit vier, acht Tonnen
diesen See aushebeln.
Genau, das will ich mir dann an. Da würde ich mir das grosse Seenbuch kaufen,
das steht drin, pass auf, du musst da irgendwie
Kies einfüllen oder was weiß ich. Ab irgendeinem Punkt sind
deine Formen auch nicht mehr googelbar. Ich glaube, See anlegen
ist schon sehr schlecht googelbar. Ja. Da fängt es dann auch irgendwann an, dass auch wirklich Google sagt, dass Google fragt, wie ist denn dein Privatleben gerade so. Oder Google sagt, gute Frage eigentlich. Ja. Hey, gute Frage. Du hast Google durchgespielt, ich habe keine Antwort. Hat mal jemand Google durchgespielt? Ich glaube schon. Also ich habe schon ein paar Mal Google gegoogelt und habe keine Ergebnisse bekommen. Ich freue mich immer bei einem Ergebnis, weil ich denke, das ist geil, hatte ich neulich wirklich. Ja, da viele Meeting, viele Namen von einem berühmten Fotografen, den habe ich nicht verstanden, den Namen, habe den gegoogelt, wie ich dachte, dass man ihn schreibt, Einsuchergebnis, Einsuchergebnis, Handball, Handballergebnisse. Ja, die guten alten Ergebnisse. Ja, Handballergebnisse, Name, aber auch nur einmal der Name, ein Handballspiel, irgendwo Nicaragua, ein Name, nie wieder gespielt, ein Tor geschlossen. Ja genau, der hat wahrscheinlich auch gesagt, jetzt habe ich die Nicaragische Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen, das höre ich. Reicht's? Nee, aber wenn du das gewonnen hättest, hättest du ja mehr Einträge. Er hätt aber nur einen Eintrag gehabt. Manchmal reicht ein Spiel, um zu gewinnen. Toll. Eingewechselt in der letzten Halbzeit, das entscheidende Tor geworfen, dann aufgehört. Ja, ich habe den Namen nicht verstanden. Wow. So, wir hören nicht auf, wir machen weiter. Wir machen weiter, ich freue mich sehr, ob deine Kühlschrankergebnisse, jetzt schon, super.
Ja, ich halte euch auf dem Laufenden, vielleicht mache ich so einen Blog, so einen Technikblog.
Ja.
Kühlschrank an aus wann ja nein.
Und so ein Webcam auf seinen Kühlschrank, finde ich auch gut.
Haut rein, macht's gut, eine ganz tolle schöne Woche, vielen Dank nochmal für das fantastische Intro.
Das war wirklich ganz, ganz toll.
Und seine Spiessgesellen, nenn sie sie.
Wir wissen nicht genau, wie sie heisst.
Macht's gut, schöne Woche, beam up.